In the skies near Japan, F-15s on the hunt...
...for a suspected North Korean intercontinental ballistic missile...
...capturing what could be its last seconds in flight.
This rare video released by Japan's military,...
...experts say the burning object resembles a ballistic missile...
...boost rocket re-entering the atmosphere,...
...flying for about an hour at hypersonic speeds.
If there's no interception or the interception fails,...
...an ICBM launched, from North Korea would take a little bit more than 30 minutes...
...to reach the homeland U.S...
...and also depending on if it's the west coast or east coast...
...east coast will take slightly more time.
Chinese scientists simulated a North Korean nuclear attack.
According to the South China Morning Post,...
...the simulation shows 33 minutes from the time of launch to the time of impact...
...if U.S. missile defenses fail to shoot down the ICBM.
Missile defense begins here.
For years, U.S. leaders have reassured the public.
The nation should be very confident.
And America's allies.
Easily shoot them out of the sky.
Missile defense systems can keep them safe.
But virtually all ballistics missiles travel at more than five times the speed of sound.
Sometimes faster.
It's been described as hitting a bullet with a bullet.
Trying to hit a warhead.
Three, two, one, ignition.
A report last year finding America's missile defense system,...
...the nation's best, perhaps only line of defense...
...only succeeds about half the time.